- That's a sad reality
because even in my country,
when I was growing
up in Lebanon,
remember Lebanon
was the only country
to accept the third wave
of Palestinian refugees
into the country
in 1974, '75.
I was a 10 year old little girl.
My father owned a restaurant,
and we were watching the images
of the Palestinians coming
into Lebanon on our television,
the first TV in town.
And I would hear the
conversations on the tables
in the restaurant,
you know, people
talking to each other.
"Oh, the bloody Jews.
Look what they're doing
to the Palestinians."
The general teaching, not
in my household, obviously,
because we are Christians,
but the general teaching
across the Arabic world
is Israel is Satan.
(speaking foreign language)
This has not changed.
It actually got worse
because in the
Palestinian Territories,
they teach the children
to hate the Jews
because the Jews have horns,
the Jews are evil,
the Jews are satanic,
and this is why you see
the barbarism happening.
But the barbarism is not new,
and it's all not
directed at Israel only.
You know, this is why people
think, "Oh my gosh, Hamas,
you know, we need to feel sorry
for the poor Palestinians."
People need to understand that
throughout the Middle East,
they have zero tolerance
for minorities,
and Israel is the
bullseye in their eye
because they could
not kick Israelis out.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining
me today is an author,
a national security expert,
and founder of Act for America,
my friend Brigitte Gabriel.
Brigitte, welcome back
to "The Rubin Report."
- Hello my friend.
I'm delighted to be
back with you again.
- I'm so glad to see you.
We don't see each other enough.
I have to say before we start,
that you accomplished something
that no other
"Rubin Report" guest
has ever done in all of
the years of the show.
You are the only guest who
ever brought tears to my eyes
during a live episode.
We'll link to the
clip down below.
But you were giving
a wonderful soliloquy
about America and freedom
and the importance
of fighting for freedom,
and you actually brought tears
to my eyes during the show.
And I feel like that's something
that has meaning,
that has meaning.
- Yes, it does.
You know why?
Because you and I
share the same soul.
We care about what
happens in the world.
We care about human suffering.
It doesn't matter
who are these humans.
You know, they could
be Palestinians,
they could be Muslims,
Christians, Buddhists.
We care about people,
but we hate evil.
We stand up against evil,
and that's why we're
talking together.
- Well, that's
exactly why I wanted
to have you on the
show this week.
So I wanna do a little recap.
You've told the
story many times,
you've written about
it and everything else,
but I thought we could
just do a few minutes
on your childhood,
growing up in Lebanon,
and sort of what led you
to being the person
that you are now.
We'll just recap that briefly,
and then I wanna talk to you
about the current events.
But your personal story, it's
just so absolutely incredible
and so relevant
to, to everything
that's happening in
the world right now.
- Exactly, especially as
we watch what's happening
between Lebanon and
Israel and Gaza.
You know, I was born
and raised in Lebanon.
Lebanon used to be
the only majority
Christian country
in the Middle East.
Most people don't know that.
We were fair-minded.
We were open-minded.
We were tolerant.
We were multicultural.
We prided ourselves on
our multiculturalism.
We welcomed everyone
into our country,
including Palestinians,
because we wanted to share
with them the Westernization,
which we had created in the
heart of the Middle East.
Unfortunately, David, we
took people into our country
who did not share our values.
My 9-11 happened to me in 1975
when actually Palestinian
Radical Islamist
blew up my home,
bringing it down,
burning me under the rubble,
wounded, as they were trying
to take over our town.
I ended up in the hospital
for two and a half months
and later ended up
living in a bomb shelter
in an eight by 10
room bomb shelter,
without water, without very
little food and no electricity.
And that's where I lived
for the next seven years
of my life, robbed of my youth.
So I understand I'm not
only a terrorism analyst
who studied about
terrorism in college.
I'm an eyewitness to terror
who live to tell about it,
and that's why I
speak so forcefully
and so passionately about
standing up to those
who want to perpetrate evil.
If we good people don't
stand up and speak out,
who else is going to do it?
- Yeah, and as you know,
my friend Gadd Sadd,
I'm sure you know, Gadd, his
parents were actually kidnapped
by Palestinian
terrorists in Lebanon.
He was Jewish or he is Jewish.
You were Christian,
but the point is
that Beirut was once
the Paris of the Middle East.
- That's right.
- And it certainly
isn't anymore.
And we'll see what happens
over the next couple weeks.
But can you quickly just
tell your journey then
of eventually how
you got to America,
because there was
even a stop in Israel,
which people would
find interesting,
and then kind of
what got you here,
and then we'll get
to today's issues.
- Well, you know, I grew
up in the bomb shelter
and Israel was
our only lifeline.
I remember when we first
went into the bomb shelter,
people would say, you know,
my father would say, you know,
"America's gonna see all the
massacres happening in Lebanon,
and America is gonna come
and France is gonna come,
and all these big Christian
nations are gonna come."
And we waited and we
waited and nobody came.
And I remember three
years into the war,
I was around 13 years old,
and we got a word that night
that our town was
going to be shelled.
And you know, a friend of ours,
a Christian militia
fighter stopped by
and he said, "I just
want you to know,
if I don't see you tomorrow,
I wish you a merciful death,
because I believe they're
gonna take us over tonight."
And I remember David
dressing in my Sunday best,
my Easter dress,
because I wanted to look
pretty when I am dead,
knowing that when they
come to slaughter me,
there would be no
one to bury me.
And I remember sobbing,
begging my mother, "I
don't want to die."
I'm only 13 years old.
And there was nothing my
mother could say to me.
And I remember sitting in the
corner of our bomb shelter,
and my father started
reading from Psalms,
"I shall walk into
the valley of death
and fear no evil for
thou art with me."
And my parents said
to me, they said,
"We lived a long life.
You are an only child.
You are a young child.
We will create a distraction
when they come to kill us.
And you just run towards
the Israeli border
and don't look back."
You see, we live
two and a half miles
from the Israeli border,
and we knew if we
run to the Jews
and beg for help, the Jews
are not going to slaughter us
because we had
more shared values
with them than we
had with the Muslims.
Thank God I did not have to
make that decision that night,
because that's the night when
Israel came in physically
into Lebanon and established
the security zone
and set up artillery
bases around our town.
And that's how we went on
living for another five years
until Israel invaded Lebanon,
working with the Christians,
trying to help the Christians
take back their country,
take back their democracy,
and kick out the
radical Islamic element
that had taken control of
the country at that time.
And that's how we came
out of the bomb shelter.
And back to
rebuilding our lives.
I ended up moving
to Israel in 1984
and becoming a news anchor
for World News in
the Middle East
based out of Jerusalem,
covering world events.
And it was there where I met
my American war correspondent,
American husband, got married.
And that's how I ended up coming
to the United States,
thinking I left
everything behind.
My life story is detailed
in a New York Times
bestseller title
"Because They Hate,"
where I go into
far more details,
like when my mother was wounded
and we ended up in
an Israeli hospital.
And so many stories in the book
that would really move
you and shed a light
about what's happening
in the Middle East
right now, so you can understand
how far back this conflict goes.
- Alright, so we'll link
to the book down below,
and we're also gonna link
to our first interview
where we spent the hour
really telling your story
because you just did
a very, very obviously
condensed version of it.
But let's get to the issues
of the last two weeks or so.
I take it that even with
the horrific barbarity
and the medieval like
nature of all of this,
that you probably,
of all people,
were not particularly surprised.
I mean, did the
Barbarity surprise you?
I know the events probably
didn't surprise you.
- What surprised me
was the attack itself,
that it was not
stopped by Israel.
That surprised the
world, not just me.
Israelis are known for
their intelligence,
but the massacre itself
did not surprise me
because I understand
how much they hate.
And that's why I titled my
book, "Because They Hate."
The venom that are being fed
from their mother's
milk to hate the Jews.
Arab children from
the time they're born,
they teach their children
how much to hate the Jews.
And that's a sad reality
because even in my country,
when I was growing
up in Lebanon,
remember Lebanon
was the only country
to accept the third wave
of Palestinian refugees
into the country
in 1974, '75.
I was a 10 year old little girl.
My father owned a restaurant,
and we were watching the images
of the Palestinians coming
into Lebanon on our television,
the first TV in town.
And I would hear
the conversations
on the tables in the restaurant,
you know, people
talking to each other.
"Oh, the bloody Jews.
Look what they're doing
to the Palestinians."
The general teaching, not
in my household, obviously,
because we are Christians,
but the general teaching
across the Arabic world
is Israel is Satan.
(speaking foreign language)
This has not changed.
It actually got worse
because in the
Palestinian Territories,
they teach the children
to hate the Jews
because the Jews have horns,
the Jews are evil,
the Jews are satanic,
and this is why you see
the barbarism happening.
But the barbarism is not new,
and it's only not
directed at Israel only.
You know, this is why people
think, "Oh my gosh, Hamas,
you know, we need to feel sorry
for the poor Palestinians."
People need to understand that
throughout the Middle East,
they have zero tolerance
for minorities.
And Israel is the
bullseye in their eye
because they could
not kick Israelis out.
I mean, look, they tried
to eliminate the
Armenians in Turkey.
The same type of
massacres, the beheading,
the killing, the stabbing
of a mother pregnant,
getting the baby out,
stabbing her in the stomach.
I mean, we're hearing
the stories out of Gaza.
They did the same thing
to the Armenians in Turkey
at the beginning of the century.
Israel didn't even exist.
2 million Armenians
were massacred.
They did it to the
Christians in Lebanon.
Yazidis in Iraq.
Have we forgotten what
ISIS did to the Yazidis.
What Hamas did to the Israelis
is basically ISIS 2.0.
Nothing has changed.
It's the same tactics
with the same barbarity
that no one in the
civilized world
should accept or stand for.
I can understand if people
wanna fight for their rights.
You know, okay, fine,
fight man to man.
Take it to the world stage.
Go to the United Nations.
Make your case.
You don't go in
and kidnap six month old
babies, five year old babies,
two year old grand babies.
You are a father, I'm a mother.
We have children.
Can you imagine somebody
taking our children?
Grandmothers who
are on medications?
This is barbaric behavior
and it's unacceptable.
- Why do you think so much
of the world seems unable,
or at least the Western
world seems unable
to see this with clear eyes?
Is is it fear?
Is it stupidity?
Is it confusion?
Is it propaganda?
- It's propaganda.
It's propaganda.
And we live in an age where
everybody does not want anybody
to say anything bad about them.
We live in the age of feelings.
It's no longer about logic.
Everything is about feeling.
It's not about whether
something is good
for you or not,
or whether something
makes sense.
It's about how do you feel?
How does this make you feel?
We live in a world that's
driven by feelings nowadays,
and it is fueled
by social media.
And so nobody wants to
see children suffering.
But when you look
at the Palestinians,
sometimes they even
fake the images
of the children
who are suffering.
They've done that in the past.
We have seen them do it.
This is not to minimize
children's suffering,
but we need to understand
that the perpetrators
of evil continue to
perpetrate their evil.
And we cannot stand for that.
But this is also aided and abed
by the leftist socialist Marxist
in the West who do not
wanna rock the boat.
And I have to tell you,
especially in the
leftist Jewish community,
I am not silenced
by the Muslims.
I am silenced, when I speak,
by the radical lefty Jews
who feel that if
I speak that way,
it could create
problems for them.
Let's not rock the boat.
I remember giving a speech
at Duke University in 2004,
and in my speech, it was a
pro-Israeli speech on the eve
of the Palestinian solidarity
movement at Duke University.
And part of my speech was,
obviously my speech
was about terrorism.
And I said,
"The difference between
Israel and the Arabic world
is a difference between
civilization and barbarism,
a difference between
democracy and dictatorship,
goodness and evil."
Do you know that it was
the Jewish community
that condemned me
and issued an apology to the
Palestinians for inviting me
because I offended
the Palestinians.
If you google my
name on social media,
every single bad article
written about me,
it's either the ADL, the
Anti-Defamation League,
the Southern Poverty
Law Center, the SPLC,
the ACLU, major
Jewish organizations.
It's not the Muslims,
it's not Care.
So sometimes it's
the Jewish community
who silences those
who are speaking up on
calling the barbarity
because they think if we are
so inclusive and so tolerant
and so into diversity,
equity, and inclusion,
they're gonna like us
because they're gonna
see how nice we are.
They don't get the problem.
- Are you getting some emails?
I'm getting an
awful lot of emails
from liberal or
lefty Jews right now
who are kind of like,
"Dave, you know, I
haven't really liked you
or listened to you over
the last couple years,
but now I'm kind of getting it."
Are you getting those two?
- Unfortunately not yet.
But I hope to get
that sometimes.
- I'll forward you a couple.
It goes to you too.
- You know, it's sad,
but you know, it's
people like you and me
who are speaking out
forcefully against evil.
And look how you were attacked.
Look how, how I was attacked.
And yet we continue to speak up
because we do it not for them,
because we do it because
of us who we are as people.
We will not sit silent watching
evil being perpetrated.
And I think it is time
for the community,
for the Jewish community,
as well as anybody who's got
a conscience in this world,
to stand up and say,
enough is enough.
And by the way, we are
the Palestinian mothers
condemning this behavior.
Where are the Palestinian
daughters saying,
look, we do not
accept the kidnapping
of six month old children,
or two year old little girls,
or the rape of teenage girls,
or the torture and rape and
humiliation of grandmothers.
Where are the Palestinian
voices speaking up right now?
- If you were in Israel
or you were an Israeli citizen,
or you were advising Israel,
what would you be telling
them to do right now?
Because it's not just the
1,300 people that are dead.
It's the 200 hostages.
It's the fact that 7,000
rockets have been shot
since this began and
are still being shot
at this very moment.
What would you tell them to do
in the face of what
you're describing?
- Look, war is ugly,
but the only way you're gonna
fight a war is to win it.
They have to win.
And yes, in war,
innocent people die.
That's a part of the
collateral damage of war.
And I am the last person in the
world who advocates for war.
I'm a survivor of war,
but I understand
that if you are fighting
a disease like cancer,
you've gotta root cancer out.
Because if you don't,
cancer is gonna kill you.
It's not an if.
It's a matter of when.
It's not a question.
And right now in
the Middle East,
if we wanna prosper
in the Middle East,
if we wanna see a prosperous
and peaceful Lebanon,
a prosperous and peaceful
Palestinian Territories,
a prosperous and
peaceful Jordan,
you have to take out
evil starting with Iran.
Iran is funding both
Hezbollah and Hamas,
and they've gotta take them out.
Have no mercy.
Go out and take them out.
- Does it sort of
seem to you like a lot
of the Arab countries,
they need Israel in a way,
like they kind of need it
because it's the scapegoat
for all of the bad things
that they do to
their own citizens.
I mean, in Lebanon,
as you described,
Palestinians can't vote.
There's I think 20 or 30 things.
They're not allowed to
be lawyers or doctors.
There's like a series of things.
Same in Jordan.
Like they sort of need
Israel to be like,
"Ah, well we're doing
some bad stuff to you,
but nah, the Jews over there."
- Well, look, the Arabs
need the Palestinians,
but at this point the
Arabs are prospering.
They are growing.
And the Palestinians,
everywhere they go,
they cause a problem.
That's the problem.
That's why Egypt doesn't
want them, you know?
I mean, that's why
they said "No way."
All they have to do is look at
what the Palestinians
did in Jordan
and what the Palestinians
did in Lebanon.
They destroyed Lebanon.
King Hussein of Jordan
bulldozed 30,000
of them back in 1974, '75,
and kicked them out.
His own wife is a Palestinian,
and he doesn't wanna take
any more Palestinians.
They are a problem
anywhere they go.
And that's why they
do not want them.
But here's the other thing.
Look, there are many
Palestinians living in America.
There are many Palestinians
living in Australia.
There are are many Palestinians
living all over the world.
They have whatever
right they want.
Look at Rashida Talib,
a member of Congress
elected in the United
States of America.
You know, why are they
still screaming about
"Oh four generations ago
we used to have a home."
What about all the Israelis,
all the Jews that were
kicked out of Arab land.
Over 1 million Jews were
kicked out of Egypt,
out of Iran, out of Lebanon,
out of Jordan, out of Syria.
They're not complaining,
"We wanna go back."
They said, "Okay,
we were kicked out.
We'll start a new
life somewhere else."
Just like I started the
new life in America.
You know, we need to move
forward with the times
and they need to get
over holding a grudge
and moving over so
everybody can live in peace.
And by the way, Dave,
one important thing,
Ahud Barak in 2000 offered them
97% of the territories, 97%.
They did not want it.
They didn't want it.
They wanted all of Israel
because they wanna
kick the Israelis out.
And most people don't
remember in 1964,
when the PLO was founded,
the Palestinian
Liberation Organization
is Gaza, was Egypt and
the West Bank was Jordan.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- The PLO was founded
to eradicate the Jews
and any latam and kick
them into the sea.
A Jordanian flag was
flying over Gaza.
They didn't call it
occupied territories then.
A Egyptian flag was
flying over Gaza,
and a Jordanian flag was
flying over the West Bank.
How come they were not
screaming about occupation then?
What the Palestinians
want is basically
to eliminate the existence
of Israel out of the
Middle East, period.
- I'm so glad you
mentioned that.
'Cause one of the things
I've really been trying to do
for the last two weeks is
tell people basic history.
And you know, there's
this whole thing now
where people are saying,
"Well, there's been an
occupation for 75 years."
And it's bizarre to me that
people seem to be calling
for the British Empire
to return, right?
I mean, that's what in
essence you'd be asking for
because there never was
a Palestinian state.
- That's right.
That's right.
There was never a
Palestinian state.
Even Jews who lived in that
region were Palestinians.
Look, Jerusalem
was desolate land.
I mean, they didn't care of it.
Have you seen picture?
People need to Google pictures
of Jerusalem back a hundred
years ago, 150 years ago.
I mean, it was nothing.
And you know, Israel,
the Israel accepted
whatever the UN gave them.
And actually the reason
why Israel is on the coast
with the sand dunes, that's
what the UN gave Israel.
The Arabs said, "Okay,
fine, give them that.
You know, they're gonna die.
You can't grow anything.
You know, it's desolate land."
The Jews turned the
desert into an oasis.
They turned it into Eden.
And then in 1967, the
Arabs attacked the Jews.
That's how you know Israel
ended up with Jerusalem.
This is how they ended up.
And look at the Yom Kippur war.
Israel gained more
land every time
the Arabs attacked Israel.
And finally, you know,
Israel doesn't want the land.
They gave the land to Gaza.
For those who are
saying occupation,
Israel withdrew out
of Gaza in 2005.
And a lot of us
did not want Israel
to withdraw out of Gaza.
Israel dragged their own
citizens out of Gaza,
literally dragged them
kicking and screaming.
And, you know, because
they wanted to give all
of Gaza to the Palestinians.
"Here it is.
It is yours.
You build it."
They left all the greenhouses.
The greenhouses,
Gaza used to export
50 million flowers a
year, just flowers,
out of the Gaza Strip,
not to mention tomatoes,
vegetables, fruits.
They used to export
all over the world.
The Israelis left all
the greenhouses behind.
I know an Israeli, a Jewish
businessman in New York,
a very lefty Jewish businessman,
gave the Palestinians $14
million so they can start
with the base money,
so they can continue
running the greenhouses,
so they can flourish
and grow their economy
and hire people.
And what did the
Palestinians do in Gaza?
Within 24 hours,
they burned 126 synagogues,
destroyed the greenhouses,
even dismantled the pipes.
So they stole the
copper out of the pipes.
They destroyed them.
These people shoot
themselves in the foot.
They could have turned
Gaza into Singapore.
- [Dave] Yep.
- But they didn't. It's
not the fault of Israel.
It's the fault of Hamas
and the Palestinians.
- Do you think the West
as a whole has the stomach
or the fortitude,
or do we even have enough
sort of cultural energy
to win this thing?
I don't mean the
specifics of this war,
but what seems to now be
brewing across all of the globe
where we're seeing
these crazy protests
in London and in Paris
and in Sydney, Australia,
et cetera, et cetera.
Do you think the West
has enough left to fight
for all the good ideas that
your life is an example of?
- Yes, the West will
have the resolve
if they have a good leader.
Look under President
Donald Trump.
You didn't see
anything happening
like this across the world.
Zip, four years,
nothing, no wars.
You know why?
Putin feared him.
Russia feared him.
Iran feared him.
China feared him.
They didn't know what was
what he was going to do.
And when you have a
leader who is so strong,
he inspires other
leaders to be strong.
And so this is how you see
the cream rising to the top.
And as soon as President
Trump was no longer
at the White House,
the whole world fell apart.
This is not a wasted
lesson on our enemies.
China, Iran, North Korea, Russia
realized under Biden,
they've got a four year
window of opportunity,
and especially
after the withdrawal
that we did out of Afghanistan.
And this is exactly
why China sent
their ships surrounding Taiwan.
Russia invaded Ukraine.
Iran now was prodding
and poking at Israel.
They realized now
they've got one year
to do whatever they wanna do.
And this is why
we must organize.
We must come together
and I urge people to go to my
website, actforamerica.org,
actforamerica.org.
We are now 2 million members
mobilizing nationwide.
We helped pass 210 bills
on the federal level
and the state level to
protect the country.
Right now, we have a
petition on the website
to stop the importation
of any Palestinian
refugee into America.
You need to take action
on that petition right now
because once the ground
invasion starts in Gaza,
watch the Democrats in our
country start screaming,
oh my gosh, we've gotta
help the Palestinian.
Now is the time to speak up
and put pressure on
your elected officials
so they can understand that
the American public is united.
We're not gonna
import Palestinian
terrorists into our country.
Go to actforamerica.org
right now.
Sign that petition as well
as the action campaign
we have to expel Rashida
Talib from Congress.
- All right, we're gonna
link to that as well.
You're gonna set a record
for the amount of links
that we're gonna
put in one show.
And Brigitte, I'm gonna
leave you with a chance
to make me cry again.
Tell me all about
freedom one more time.
- You and I are so
passionate about freedom
because we understand
what's at stake.
I fight this war not because
somebody else is gonna like me.
You cannot believe the
hate mail that I get.
death threats that I get.
- [Dave] No, I can believe it.
- Yeah, yeah, you
probably got some too.
- I can believe it.
But yeah, some other
people couldn't.
- I do what I do because I
wanna be able on my death's bed
to be able to look
at my children
and tell them I did everything
I can to preserve freedom
for you so you can live in a
great and prosperous country.
This is what I wanna
leave for my children.
Freedom is only one generation
away from extinction.
That's why we need
to fight for freedom.
We need to stand together and
we need to fight together.
This is a fight between
civilization and barbarism.
This is the fight between
goodness and evil.
We need to be on
the side of good.
- Brigitte, you
never disappoint.
It was good to see you.
- Thank you my friend.
Have a great day.
(upbeat music)
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop screaming,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.